αποτέλεσματο ότι έχουμε να παιδάκι γιά μας από και και πέρα νομίζω ότι όλα τα
άλλα ήταν θέμα χαρακτήρα ήταν θέματρόκανο ότι είμαστε και η άγι πάντε υπάρχους καμπανεβάσματα σε
μια σχέση εγώ έχω μάθει να κάνοάντα κάποιες φορές κάνει και η έλενα και πήρκαμε
τη συνταγή είναι μεγαλητερι θαύμαστριάσου είναι ναι εναι είναι εκεί ι θέόλα τα λλάνει στην
αρχή δεν ήταν βέβαια στην αρχή που ερατο βράδυ μέχρι να κοιμηθό μιλούσο απέντε όρες
μας δεί της τα μηνήματα και τα λιπά την επόμενη μέρα στη νύχτα είναι λίγο
περίεργη νυχταόσο καλοπαιδί κια να μουφαίνεσαι φοβάμε ένα δύο τρεις μήνες παρακουργό κατάλαβε ότι δεν
έχει καμία σχέση το ά η δουλειά σου είναι δουλειά δημοσιότητας είναι στον άνθρωπο επαιδήμοάμα
ο άνθρωπος του όχι να μην είνι σε αυτά λίγο πως να τόπουμε βάλοτος δε
σε πούλησαν στυνεγάδε σταύρο βέβαια αλοιμόνο μα για από τη δικήμουμερία ίσως κάποια στιγμή μπορεί
και να πούλησα κάποιους είναι με στο παιχνίδι και αυτά όταν θε πουλούσαν πως αντιδρούσες
ή το άφηνες να περάσει και πάμε για άλαόχιμακάρι να είχα αυτό το χαρακτηριστικό ή
με δυνατόσα χαρακτήρας ή με βάλω τος όμος τα χαρακτήρας όταν στε ναχωρηθώ ήνιωσο αδικία
μπορεί να μεπάρει και μια δύο μέρες έτσι ισκέψει και μετά λέων στην αρχί όλα
για κάποιο λόγο γίνονται για καλώ και αυτό θα με δυναμώσει να αποδείξω όχι μόνο
στον άλλο δι έκανε λάθος περισσότερος εμένα θνα θε ρωτήσω στην κύπρο σήμερα μπορεί ένας
τραγούδεις της να διοποριστεί δηλαδή να απει ότι θα σχοληθώ μόνο